this is a real privilege for me we are
here today with dr. Verner bogles he is
the CTO of Amazon and of course has a
lot of really exciting experience with
that and so we're gonna be talking to
him today about his experience with
Amazon about his experience with
startups and about lots of technical
topics as well that will be relevant to
many of us so thank you all and let's
give it up for dr. Boles thank you okay
so we're gonna be talking of course
about Amazon today and about your role
there but I'd like to start with a
little bit of background would you mind
telling us about your career before you
started at Amazon and sort of what
brought you to that point how much time
do we have
so I'm sorry I was an academic before I
joined Amazon so I'd been research
scientist at Cornell for 10 years
building very large scale distributed
systems and NS as in common in in
American academia you to be motivated to
do startups on the side so we did two
startups on the side one of them that
already existed when I joined them and
they got sold off and were successful to
a company called Stratos I don't know if
anybody remembers that this before your
time yeah and an another company that
actually failed so we had both
experiences that was great kind of so
before that so I'm not the typical sort
of computer scientist there wasn't until
28 when I decided to actually to go back
to school I worked in hospitals before
that a radiotherapy in the Dutch Cancer
Research Institute doing radiotherapy in
cancer patients and I don't know what I
realized that I really hated all these
people dying around me and so it's I
decided to go do something that had no
humans involved whatsoever so computer
science seemed like a really good thing
to go into and this is me mid mid 80s so
you know the computer scientists know
where where it is now - - today but
turn out I had a humans back then I had
put it like that yeah so turn out I had
a gift for it and I didn't know that up
front so but and from there I wanted to
research because I worked as for the
kind set kind of things that I really
was interested in comma pitch the
working poor to go for a number of years
in a Research Institute and then was
invited to come to Cornell and then at
one moment it so what I did do around
that time also when I was still at
Cornell was actually either consult for
large companies like Nike HP's and the
sons and whatever of this world and also
often gave talks and so at one moment
Amazon invites me to come give talk
about sort of some of the material I was
working on and I think like really
really have to go what is this this is a
book shop you know it's a web server in
a database how hard can it be
yeah one glimpse in that kitchen however
and I realized that this is a a massive
technology operation is not a retailer
it's a technology company and and
operating at the scale that I'd never
seen before
definitely not at all the companies that
are consulted for and so the challenges
that they were faced with from from a
distributed systems researcher
perspective or amazing and so I didn't
need to think very hard when they
offered the new job well that's
incredible so that's interesting
do you feel like that was a change like
today sort of like the interesting
distributed systems problems are kind of
like huge companies and maybe before
with academia or or was that just that
it's the way yeah I'm gonna go I think
that still is the case I think I think
most distribution researchers have
become more aware sort of the kind of
scale that these very large companies
need to operate or not even these very
large companies I think if you think
about you know any successful internet
company or digital-only company needs to
operate at the scale that is
unparalleled
you know 2004 and I joined Amazon I mean
many of you if you're gonna be
successful will be easily operating at
that particular scale that Amazon was at
in 2004 but there was no body of work
that you could really be relying on
those the
the chatty with a lot of effort went
into basically keeping the lights on
long things that iCloud and other
technologies now gives you and so Amazon
that gotten it 2004 to scale purely by
being practical and it's not that you
there was a book or so that you could
read how to build a scalable
organization or a scalable company you
know it didn't
and so everything I was almost sort of
Amaya is five to ten years ahead of the
curve both in terms of the usage of
technology of the development of
technology but also at the operation of
scale and especially if you want to be a
fast-moving company it's not like you
could look at traditional enterprises
because they are all sort of a might
suffer form innovators dilemma and all
the things are really slow at one moment
once they become sixty success or how to
build a company that needs to continue
to move fast it's a whole different
story and and so they may be you may be
doing things that you may be making
business trade-offs for example the
creation of technical debt or the
allowing duplication to happen and
things like that that would be out of
the question in the traditional
enterprise because efficiency is their
their main goal at Amazon moving fast
and innovating fast and having them very
long pipeline of experiments that's the
more and most important things and
you're willing to allow duplication to
happen you allow to create technical
depth as long as you know that you have
to pay it off so the many trade-offs
that I must one has been willing to make
over time that you can't find in the
traditional MBA book so most of these
things I'm also had to develop for
themselves and whether it's technology
or whether it's processes or business
processes that helps of course that with
Jeff basis at the helm you have someone
who's a true visionary and truly
understands sort of how the next modern
world will look like or should look like
Thanks so a couple of years after you
joined you were appointed the CTO of
Amazon and
someone asked you do you want to be the
CTO guys he's not gonna ask next year is
he no so alpha mutant who was that
company by the way didn't really he
really wanted to be developer and they
had been looking for a green replacement
for him and as I said early sometimes
you have gifts that you don't know about
until you start doing them and so I
think I joined in September and freaking
January I became the CTO well so tell me
what that was like at Amazon and then
sort of what that role has shifted into
as we get told today yeah so if you if
enactment so and one of the things that
Amazon sort of one of the reasons for
hiring me and actually a few of my
abroad actually was it about five of my
students former students with me and I
came there was really two in straight
more sort of academic rigor into the way
that we wanted to approach scaling where
Amazon had become really good at scale
but the challenge was that we wanted to
do orders of magnitude more in in
essence we go from order of magnitude
growth you have to revisit almost
everything that you do whether it's your
processes but also your technologies and
so to really be on a solid footing to do
sort of the next one or two orders of
magnitude of growth that were coming we
needed to sort of insert way more rigor
into our thinking and it was for example
around performance how do you measure
what kind of infrastructure do we need
for measurements how do you if you want
to be a truly data driven company that
sort of makes data different decisions
you need to first of all faster data but
you also need to have a culture around
how do you measure or and how do you
interpret those those measurements and I
mean a medium latency of let's say one
point two seconds of your webpage to
your customers doesn't say anything just
says that 50% of your customs have a
worse experience you need to know how
much worse and then from an engineering
it so for example the 99th percentile or
the 99.9% of it's way more important
often in those cases and then how do you
create an engineering discipline that
has control over that 99 percentile so
cheeky can actually start pulling it in
if that's what you want to do and then
be able to associate that with business
decisions for example I mean the
commonality is that if you improve
latencies of your pages conversion goes
up and so the question then is how much
are you willing to spend to drive that
conversion of you need to have more
capacity you need to do more engineering
and so when when you have a diminishing
return on sort of the investments that
you have to make that Icahn control so
all year we focused really on
performance and measurement the things
that also bit in progress already when I
joined live the whole year on focusing
on single points of failure really I
think in 2004 we were pretty good in
terms of reliability there were rules
around so we had to use data centers you
have to replicate whatever he did over
these see data centers you be able to
lose a data center customer she not be
impacted she could lose two data centers
customer can be impacted terms of
latency but not in functionality all of
those rules were there and I think we
were pretty good at it until at one
moment we decided so why don't we pull
the plug out of one of these data
centers and see what happens and the
first time I redid this was not like we
made it as a surprise now we gave
everybody a heads up that this is what
we're going to do we're not really
propylene to plug let me pull you pull
the network basically yeah so data
center gets gets isolated turns out all
these things that look great on paper
didn't really look that great in
practice although the first time when
you do it now lots of manual processes
steel manual database failover swings
like that this is all pre AWS and so
that's sort of a whole year focusing on
that and so by the time you do the third
or the fourth of these what we call game
days you actually get to a point where
these things will come really well
automated and that you can actually do
them without human intervention one
biggest surprise when we did the first
time was and then you bring the other
data center back online and then
certainly that data center has to sync
with the other data centers get man
that's a nightmare that was a scenario
that nobody had thought about and so but
until you do these things you don't know
them and especially at scale so
and then we did here on efficiency with
it's a lot of things so mostly the world
of a CTO is to drive really big programs
I would think about sort of what does
the technology that we need for the
future to be able to be on solid footing
as a business or in the case of Amazon
what are the kind of unique technologies
that we've developed that may be able to
turn into a business then things change
at all moment because in early 2000 we
had opened up the cathode we put an API
on the catalog that was popular in those
days you just put an API on something
see what innovation happens and it turns
out lots of great companies were being
built so you would have access to the
catalog search shopping cart and if you
want more from snails anyway so lots of
new e-commerce completely being built
based on the Amazon catalog they would
do comparison shopping and have
wonderful new you eyes towards the whole
site really great stuff being built but
as soon as one of those companies became
successful they all started to stutter
in the execution they all needed to get
investment not because they needed to
operate do the business operations the
only to start buying hardware and they
need to hire IT people and so all these
investment was in in essence in indirect
funding of the American hardware
industry yeah because now and that was
where all them so all these companies
had hard time doing that they had hard
time getting the investment at the hard
time getting the hardware because you
know you might order 50 service it's not
like driving up to Costco and actually
getting them in your shopping cart know
it's and then hire IT people and things
like that
so most of those companies that were
initially successful around the Amazon
Catalog all failed and they didn't fail
because they didn't have great ideas
they fail because they couldn't get your
IT stuff ready or get the money to
actually do to do to that and I think
one of the things that has shifted with
with AWS and cloud is that the
investment that you get no longer goes
in large numbers to hardware companies
it goes into hiring more people that are
relevant for your company and actually
build your products better so so then we
become Toby we started eight AWS and we
could talk more about that later
but when you become a technology
provider your world assisity all changes
I think there's sort of a voting bloc
postpones about that is in my eyes is
sort of four different types of safest
folks ask any last come every last
company of office it will be different
but I think there's sort of four large
categories one ISM in enterprises
they're often sort of the the
infrastructure manager yeah they will
report to the CIO managers large amount
of infrastructure and then there is sort
of the second world or think is that of
what you often see in younger businesses
where the sitios did the technical
co-founder the technical did one with
the technical vision I do think that
that the world is a dangerous one
because there's so many other things
that actually fall into that bucket in
terms of VP of engineering teams and
things like that the teachers may not
necessarily be really good at but to
talk about that later then there is the
role of a big finger that's really where
you're sort of driving innovation if you
look at companies like 18t and loosened
and others the all that ceos has had an
office of the CTO that will be really
building next-generation technologies or
experimentation there and then it's the
role of the external facing
technologists if you're a technology
provider to other companies there's a
role of foreign executives to actually
interact at a tech deep technical level
with your customers to understand how
are you using my products yeah and and
looking for debating bigger patterns
among your customers what are the bigger
pain points that they still have not
only with our technology but just in
general you know if often jokingly said
so we're in the we're in the business of
pain management AWS yeah so what kind of
pain do customers still have that they
have to do work on that actually don't
contribute to the products that they
want to build and so that's sort of on
one hand helping customers understand
things sort of being a bit of the
evangelist for the whole notion of of
cloud which definitely they say 10 years
ago was much more important that it is
now but then most importantly take the
feedback from your customers back and
start thinking about sort of what new
features or products or you have to do
or what kind of processes we need to
change to make sure your we serve our
customers better and so it's a much more
customer focused position than a
technology focused one great um I'm
curious you were talking earlier about
you know especially in the early days
there were lots of tasks like you know
the game day you were talking about to
make sure that the infrastructure was up
for scale I'm curious if you've noticed
in your time and Amazon as it as it's
grown in the engineering culture has
grown so much are there any like tips or
tricks you've seen on how to grow an
engineering culture and keep it moving
quickly you know keep it effective well
given that Amazon is in reality my first
real job for a long time I thought that
the rest of the world was just like
Amazon and it's not there's a very
unique culture at Amazon I think that
works really well for fast-moving
companies and that is to have to build
your teams as independent as possible to
remove as much hierarchy and structure
from your organization as that is both
hierarchy in my eyes is totally
unnatural I mean you need to have some
form of IQ maybe for reporting or things
like that or for some management pieces
but you know if you look at nature
there's a head monkey and all the other
monkey's there are no lieutenant monkeys
yeah and so no I mean you may have
multiple groups of this we've always
there has monkey but there is and it
scales really well I mean if you look at
ants and also to all the patterns in
nature if you're able to build the self
or self-organizing organization which
means basically that you hire people
that really want to be independent not
want to be followers now that actually
want to own a piece of the product and
actually take ownership on that I think
that's extremely important when you're a
younger business yeah where you don't
need followers you don't need just
coders you need people that want to have
ownership over the piece that you want
and I think look for that there is
something at Amazon that we call the
leadership principles there's 14 of them
and basically that's all around culture
and so it's a custom obsession ownership
dive deep and so this
14 of them check them out if you type
them in your favorite search engine
you'll find them if a deep explanation
of all of them but that's really dries
what the Amazon culture is and so when
we hire let's say we bring in someone
for an interview you probably really
figured out whether he or she is
including of engineer through the phone
interviews and things like that you
interview all about culture it's really
do you have a real good culture fit
because there's nothing worse than a bad
hire when it comes to sort of the
culture kind of a van because that sort
of disrupt your small teams tremendously
so at Amazon we've some believe him into
two in fairly small team so 10 to 12
people if you because we tend to tell
people you're still everybody knows of
each other what you're doing yeah and I
mean by the way if you won't squirm
if you want to stand in the corridor in
the morning with 25 people that doesn't
work yeah and so you're really focusing
on small teams and making sure that they
have strong ownership over the pieces
that they need to do and so yeah one of
the building teams that are have you
know our independent thinkers have
control want to have control over their
own destiny
I think it's important I think one of
the challenges is when when you grow
with a young business often I mean the
role of a city or region is probably
that it does everything that has to do
with tech let's basically think about
the technology but also manage the teams
now I think managing teams is a
completely different discipline now
there's a major difference between what
I would call VP of engineering and the
CTO VP of Engineering every morning
wakes up thinking do I have the absolute
best team is my team in the best
position to deliver what they need to
deliver
it's a people person where I'm really
thinking about making sure that your
engineers in the right position to
deliver the technology that in the
products that they need to deliver CTO
things about technology are we building
the right tech detect technologies are
we do we have the right tools do we have
all of these kind of things so two very
different jobs in my eyes and that of a
VP of engineering so it I think it's a
you guys know my calab rants I think you
see well-known as sort of the bloggers
right these pieces if you're a manager
if you think about managing think in
terms of technology management he's
probably sort of the most well known
model writer that that really were
things deeply about how do you make
teams effective and that's very
different and he but he's not a CTO he's
a VP of engineering and so I think that
sort of really embodies that can evoke
box about it as well so really check out
his stuff Michael lob rants is his his
rants and responds we suppose I think is
the blog so really check this example
great so you mentioned earlier that in
sort of the early days of Amazon you had
those those companies integrating with
you and they were failing for the
infrastructure reasons and then it's
always that where AWS came from or tell
me how did the idea for a do us happen
how did that get get popular internally
well so if we so internally we're gems
on the retailer and and AWS as well now
I'm more or less organized in such
independent teams that most of those
teams look like startups as well yeah
and all right there they have complete
control over their own destination and
believe me the recommendation engine for
boots is very different than the
recommendation engine for shoes yeah and
so there's a different team that
different goals have their own
innovation agenda all developed by the
team themselves by the by the by the way
so what we'd gone through a number of
architectural changes so end of the 90s
and so Amazon's goal was to get big fast
and you were basically violating all
sort of architectural principles to get
to that point that meant it had ended up
with some sort of monolith and a massive
database infrastructure in the backend
that was very brittle and basically
couldn't go anymore
yeah from an architectural point of view
so but remember that nobody had done
this before so they can't be blamed it's
not like you're violating the textbook
there was no textbook and so then Amazon
moves to what's called a
service-oriented architecture that was
not a word that they existed around that
time either so carving
of pieces of the monolith bringing
together the data that they operated on
putting an API on it and then ever
networked infrastructure that can call
these public health services and and
basically that took two to three years
to get that done mostly because there
was again now history around how do you
run services and so basically by what we
were doing we were swinging the pendulum
all the way to the other end so in this
one with the monolith the whole set of
databases were a shared resource and
basically the constraint
yeah because shared resources are the
thing that sort of make you move slower
what we saw what are the reasons for
changing architecture was that we saw
that the the effectiveness of engineers
was dropping off basically deployments
were coming slower new new features were
getting slower all these kind of things
on why because the backend databases
were managed by a group of DBAs yeah and
so database administrators the DBA cabal
and to make any any schema changes she
had to go through them and these guys
were responsible for these databases so
they were as conservative as that you
can imagine yeah because the reliability
of the site dependent on them so that's
so all that we sort of our effectiveness
in innovation was really dropping off
and so moving to this new architecture
we traded all these themes that weren't
going to be independent at the code they
would have their own data stores there's
no longer a centralized data store is no
longer single and centralized resources
things like that
so all great except for that we've made
some mistakes there so what one of them
gets to see years later we carved off
all these pieces the monolith is largely
gone all services since I mean that's a
side story we've made a mistake in the
three very large data sets customers
items
that's the catalog and orders and we
basically taken all the code that
operated on that particular data as
being one service within two years that
was as big as that the monolith was yeah
so we and so we had to decompose into
much smaller functional building blocks
for example if you talk about the item
master so the customer master service
the basic consisted of ten different
smaller services each with their own
unique scale
reliability capabilities and so for
example if there would be a login
service in there that basically is
called on every webpage but in that same
piece of software also said the address
book service that only is needed really
checkout and so but that whole thing
needed to scale at the scale of the
login service because that was the one
that requires most scale so decomposing
that into different building blocks that
each after unique scaling and
reliability or maybe security
requirements made that we went to what
now is called the micro services
architecture okay so move forward all
these teams have small their own their
piece and then we see the effectiveness
of these teams tapering off again
because what happens that each of those
services now becomes I needs to scale
they all need to work on the same thing
you only to manage heart they only to
manage the load balancers Hardware
databases they're not each of the teams
now is responsible for actually
replicating the database of a seed event
of a three different day datacenter so
actually all these teams you see the
communication between these teams and a
networking infrastructure increasing was
always new tick is being created all
this work being done but they're not
working on innovation they're not
working on keeping the experimental
pipeline going so it was another red
flag and what I realize was that all
these teams are doing the same thing
because it's wrong dependent to that
side that now he had to manage your own
database so dropping actually databases
into a shared services platform dropping
storage dropping networking in the end
and for example also dropping making it
an environment where he would where
servers no longer a servers but became
virtual and you could actually manage
them so we I think we were really good
in those days in terms of hardware
provisioning so as an engineer we come
to a portal you would fill in what
unique you need 10 more Linux servers of
this particular size and now or two
later you would have them and if you can
imagine at the end of the year to
exchange giving the spikes of spikes are
four times as high so you would have a
need teams need to know a lot more
hardware if you then would go talk to me
in January and tell them why ain't you
releasing any capacity well you know
there's this project coming up in March
that we fought and we just hang on to it
and apparently just an hour to get
capacity is not enough is not a good
enough incentive to sort of release
stuff again so we needed to go to a
mobile first of all where you could take
engineers out of the loop and we could
have business rules that decide how much
capacity is applied to something so
things needed together when the server's
needed to become virtual they needed to
get an API fix that so we built these
things for ourselves internally what we
look at these companies are failing on
the outside that required scale we look
like could we solve this for ourselves
then starting to think to say some of
those technologies or not the
technologies themselves but think about
how had we had built them for internal
and then rebuild them on on the outside
and so the first one we launched was I
must want to see the simple storage
service in in spring of 2006 storage for
the internet that's what we called it
and so really in the early days thinking
that this would be targeted at but I now
would call internet scale companies I
don't like to be used to it startups
because I think there's many other types
of businesses that eventually he quiet
internet scale and that this really sort
of where we were pushing for storage
became the first firm we launched ec2 in
the fall of that that year same kind of
mobile and interfaces that we used in
the internally where suddenly compute
capability became programmable within a
few months enterprises to figured out
that this was a way to go to deal for
them as well and we know what the
stories in since then so I am curious I
mean at the time as you were developing
this before it was released did Amazon
have a sense I mean it's it's a dominant
product now in the world it's changed
the way developers work at small and
large companies did you really have that
belief coming in this is gonna change
the landscape or was it just sort of
like an iterate and every year more
people are using it and it just slowly
grew into what it is today I I think one
of the things that that we were
I won't take caught off-guard by is that
how fast it grew that was definitely did
we know was going to be really big yes
that was the bet that we were making so
an Amazon just two types of innovation
that happens one of them is that each
by themselves is in charge of the
innovation world map for the coming year
that so teams do that for themselves so
as I said the recommendation engine for
shoes who has as a metric to reduce the
number of returns yes so can you
recommend so if this this fallacy knows
nine fitted you really well if you want
to buy this Jimmy Choos maybe doing
eight and a half yeah this seems silly
but it's you know doing returns it's a
it's a tax it's a customer unfriendly
conferring so the more you can do that
so those guys our in charge of building
a world map for the coming year how to
get new data sources how to maybe
engaged if your customers differently
and that's a that's something they make
up themselves then there's no way
there's no top-down saying and down
shelf duties so that's one level of
innovation the other level is the one
that requires significant capital
investment and that was clearly
something that AWS falls into that
particular category things like the
Kindle Amazon Prime others are all
things that to do that we needed to do
significant capital investments then I'm
also we have to rule that if you do that
if it's going to be successful it needs
to be successful in a way that has
significant impact on the Amazon balance
sheet you know it's not that we're
interested in another let's say hard
that sounds quite a bit another fifty
million dollar opportunity now where if
you make these capital investments you
need to look for really big
opportunities so we knew that if AWS was
going to be successful there was going
to be massively successful in a way that
sort of we'd never seen before we knew
that we had to develop lots of new
processes and technologies and
techniques and whatever for all of this
if it was going to be successful now
remember when we were developing SC we
wrote a number on the board that before
o and within six months were probably
let's build this for this number of
objects in the storage engine and then
just for the heck of it we put two
orders of magnitudes behind it that blew
through that in the first three months
yes oh now it suddenly it turns out that
sort of that we some decisions we made
early on
from a technology point of view were
really smart we knew that if you would
with every order of magnitude of growth
you probably need to revisit your
architectures that you have so you need
to build software that needs to be able
to evolve over time evolved and for
example take a storage engine if you go
to the next release internally of your
software you can't just copy the massive
amount of petabytes that you have on the
other storage disks to do this now so
you have to live with multiple
architectures at the same time multiple
versions all these kind of things
fortunately and with all the lessons
from amazon.com we it's actually taking
the right steps there there's been some
challenges over time in that that sense
and but I think also just like with any
other company it's not only the tech
that you have to to to scale when I
think early days at AWS I believe we
said something like we don't need any
salespeople this stuff will sell itself
yeah this is all self-service well turns
out that's not the case yeah it turns
out you need solution architect you need
technical account managers you need a
customer support you need all these kind
of things to build around your product
they have nothing to do with the tech
itself but you cannot become successful
company read without that I was looking
just right before this interview
actually and I was looking at sort of
the AWS directory page and there's I
don't know I think it was like a hundred
and thirty services and probably that
number will change you know by the time
we finish this conversation I'm curious
how do you as an organization determine
like how do you decide to build
something new is there like is it a
top-down process is it just an
individual team what does that look like
to launch something new I think there's
a workspace I think there is I mean we
expect all of our teams as they are now
to being very close contact with our
customers so about 95% of features and
services that we deliver are in response
to direct requests from our customers
and so that's and that's a massive
influx of course the early early
services that we built you
could almost think about what they
should be no I mean what is the basic IT
infrastructure storage compute databases
network security yeah I mean that that's
you didn't need customers to actually
sort of tell you that we knew that those
were their basic pieces that we needed
to build but pretty quickly customers
came with also the photo requests I mean
if I look at the sort of fun kind of
things that a BBS was really good at at
the fundamental level the scale
performance security reliability and
managing cost those are not profits on
the outside but those are sort of core
capabilities that come back in each and
every one of these services and so
customers then came to us they said well
you know can't you want analytics for us
and this this is the early days so
everything about analytics around IOT
about mobile development about you know
that these days blockchain all these
other technologies that customers
actually want to use do not want to
manage themselves yeah an asset you know
will be helping them sort of putting up
the the right features or tools and this
is important and we also had a very
strong culture around when we launch new
products new services we will want him
with a minimal feature set you could
call it an MVP yeah but that sounds like
that's that I mean this is technology
where other people need to build their
business on so you can't actually launch
things that are flaky needs to be rock
solid so in the launch rings rocks or
believe a minimum feature set and then
work with your customers on what should
the other features be now in general we
Lin have an inkling what the other
features are going to be when we launch
DynamoDB for example we really knew
customers wanted secondary indices we
didn't launch with them but that was
obvious that that was what they wanted
mostly it launched with with a minimum
feature set because these are sometimes
services nobody else has used before and
nobody built and so you need to observe
your customers how they're going to use
your product because you don't know up
front like see they probably use it in
every possible way except for the one
that you intended it to that is good
because if it didn't launch if
everything in the kitchen sink then sort
of you can focus on how your customers
are using your product and then slowly
start to iterate and adding new features
and services to it
in the way that sort of their new modern
way of development is we're working yes
when we launched lamda which is our
service environment so basically you
just write code you dump it in in SC and
you can just you don't need to think
about servers and anything else you
don't need to think about idle time you
don't have to pay for what you use
things that upgrade environment nobody
done that before so how its development
gonna change what's the kind of other
support structures around it
yeah or rittany maybe we launched it
much more as an event-driven environment
so the new file arrives in SC it
triggers some codes you know a new
message arrives it triggers some code
API gateway things like that but it
turns out some of the companies that
actually immediately jumped on board a
server for some of the largest
enterprises why because you don't need
to manage anything there and you don't
need to pay if no execution happens I
mean if you run a whole batch of ec2
instances whether you use them or not
turn
you're being built for them and in this
case the only being built for execution
and so it changes the way the
development happens so you don't launch
everything and the kitchen sink I said
earlier around servers you're going to
see how your customers are using this
and they quickly start iterating with we
develop it x-ray as being the debugging
environment
deliver step functions to build more
complex applications and there's just a
lot of more things coming down in that
pipeline mostly because you can observe
how your customers are using your
product so for example in dynamodb we
new secondary indices turns out
customers want to throw an item levels
access management much more important
for them than secondary indices so
basically customers reordered our
roadmap to be able to sort of and then
we started delivering the things that
mattered most to them which i think is
an important part in this but again even
though it looks like an MVP we can't
treat it like an MVP because people will
be building their business on it and
will be depending on it so it comes with
a very different culture structure on
that so last year 1400 new features and
services as the number of teams grow
of course accelerates as well and and so
we use within a DBS sort of the same
structure the the Neptune team the graph
database is supposed to be in contact
with their most important customer most
let's say demanding customers and
understand what their needs are and so
each of these teams has their own
customer set and customer base and and
all built a run web map the more
services you get the more web maps you
get but you know this is a is really a
very fast-moving environment where the
way that people are building software is
changing dramatically changed
dramatically as well if we would have
sort of taken the step in deciding for
our customers how they should develop
software you probably would be having
been developing software in let's say in
the way that five years ago software ten
years ago because that sort of the
structure you have this time of it we
need to decide developing software how
we would like to develop software in
2020 or 2025 that's kind of the thinking
that we have we can't do that by
deciding for your customers you need to
work closely with them and allow them to
sort of drive your innovation engine
about a decade ago you wrote a blog post
called I think working backwards you
remember what I'm talking about
um I was cured I'm curious could you
describe sort of the product development
flow that you put in that post and then
tell me what you learned and whether
Amazon still uses that structure we use
it everywhere and so it's it's a so the
protocol working from the customer
backwards so Amazon with a very strong
focus on sort of developing only those
things that really matter for your
customer so even though we're technology
company and I think if you're a heavy
technology company lots of engineering
there's a there's a risk that the
engineers get in charge yeah if they get
in charge you do not necessarily build
products you build technology and so for
us it's a drink that's agreed there's a
big difference between the two I think
what makes a be we ask for example
successful is because we focus on
products meaning what do we want to
build for our customer much more like oh
this is this very cool storage system it
sits underneath there that we've never
built
before or how do we do global tables in
DynamoDB or so this is all this amazing
tech that we building but that's not
what's driving it is what do you want to
build for your customer but it's the
problem you want to solve for them so we
want to make sure that emitter that is
in AWS or whether that is in retail or
whether it is opening a new office in a
Menlo Park we use a process called
working backwards why are we doing this
so the first thing you do is you write a
press release and it's not there's not a
press release that will come out this is
a press release you write for yourself
in which we describe in in very clear
and simple terms exactly what you're
going to build then you write a document
which that's a the 20 most frequent
questions and then you have to answer
those the very clean simple terms as
well sometimes especially for more
complex situations we iterate on those
forward to first two documents maybe 10
to 15 times until it's really absolutely
exactly clear what you're going to build
and not more than that then you write
the UX document basically how are my
customers going to use this or what is
the interaction if the customer is going
to come to B and then the fourth
document is part of the user manual
glossary and some other terms things
like that at the end of that you have a
set of four documents that describes
exactly what you're going to do and then
the ruling with the elements on is that
and thou shalt not be even built more
than that because as engineers and I'm
going myself you have the tendency to
sort of anything that should that makes
it easy for you to build version two no
matter what I start putting that in
version one that's not an option
yeah it's really focusing on building
that and exactly only that it gives us a
really strong structure around how to
think about customers how to feel about
think about products much more about
them about tech technology so this is
the product you want to build now what
kind of technologies do we need to four
or five or four for that so there's a
very strong product thinking around that
it combines with another process that we
have
so meetings at Amazon we have a
moratorium on using slides so no
PowerPoint no key no nothing like that
why because in meetings I think slides
are deadly half of the room will be on
their phones and the other half will be
already complaining by slide number two
that they don't understand what you're
talking about that's obvious because you
haven't seen the whole presentation yet
so we we operate in Amazon with what's
called six pages this is a six page
document a narrative that you have to
write and the first 30 minutes of a
meeting will always be spent by reading
this document in complete silence
sometimes halfway through the reading
you go like guys go back to the drawing
board you know don't waste our time here
because why because it is very important
because it's very hard to write a clear
document if you do not have clarity of
mind writing and narrative is extremely
hard and this might be this often a
collaborative effort you why did you
give it to some of your colleagues for
feedback you put it in your drawer I
week later you pick it up again and you
revise it until you get to a point where
you think you're really clear about
describing what that's a feature or a
product or an activity or new business
that you want to go into and and after
reading those six pages for 30 minutes
everybody in the room is on the same
page no pun intended battery for an
intent that whatever Allah says so no
and so you get a fairly high quality
discussion after that because everybody
is now is exactly what were you talking
about so now often part of that process
is then as an addendum to the sixth page
it will be DPR and FAQ and you'll
iterate for Londo so we have a very
unique culture around that five years
ago container sorry virtualization was
still pretty new a lot of companies were
just moving to that today everything is
being containerized you have lots of big
customers moving to lambda2 sort of
totally server list platforms
where do you think development is going
to go five years from now what how are
we going to be building our apps if I
would have this crystal ball I will be
sort of I do think I see quite a few
companies skipping skipping the
container step more and more not not
that I think you know so I think there
is a there's I think some part of the
popular the the pile of I think what
what come makes containers popular one
thing there is everybody wanted to go to
more micro services environment and I
think that map's really well sort of if
container tech technologies we can scale
things up and down easily in these
single components that you have and so I
think that matches the micro services
thinking really well I think most of the
people that actually come into that
phase often come out at the Molalla face
or at the breaking autumn on live into
sort of those container
people that start from scratch more and
more develop around sort of server the
server environments and so you could
even consider so for a brief an AWS to
container products wellness is easy as
the elastic container service it's all
around docker and dr capabilities and
things like that and deep integration of
all the able services and then this eks
which could be minutes could be neither
service and so that's how we started off
the thing with with the thing with
containers is especially before we
deliver the Fargate and I'll talk about
it in a minute
is that basically it almost brings you
back to the pre cloud days certainly you
need to manage multiple containers over
multiple availability zones your your
there's almost so much they need to map
them onto virtual machines because these
things don't run by themselves
you still need to manage all virtual
machine environment underneath there so
even though containers is a great sort
of development expert abstraction it
customers need to do a lot of work to
Windows contain so part of that will be
taken care of because it's a managed
service we also delivered something is
called fire gate so far gate basically
takes away all the management of virtual
machines and underneath there so
basically
just write a container you drop it in
there Aaron's kind of that's how you
that's the state where you want to be
and yeah I think every time we you need
to do things that actually have nothing
to do with building your product or
running your product in in most
efficient way then that's sort of a
waste of effort and so we continue to
look at how can we take more and more of
those pain points away because you know
what nobody cared who were winning
containers nobody cared about the future
machines underneath there yes it's just
the text that you had to pay and I think
we were sort of bringing up especially I
think the interaction in the kubernetes
group is really feeding many things back
into sort of the mainstream crew bonitas
open source environment especially when
it comes to things like security and
things like that so how are we how I
doing things differently five years or
that was the question yeah I think
there's a lot more service development
because I think we see already an
enormous pick up in the mountain I think
we'll see more and more tools and sort
of support platforms in infrastructure
around the ability to build more complex
service environments better integration
I think with other services that's
definitely things that we'll see but I'm
gonna shift to something else I think
one thing that we will be doing I hope
five years from now is that everybody
will be taking security as their
number-one job whether you're the CEO
whether the CTO whether you're an
engineer we all need to become security
conscious and we all need to become
security engineers I think if you've
looked at the past four or five years I
mean there isn't a week that goes by
where there is not some massive data
breach it's embarrassing I think process
technologists and as energy and as
digital business leaders we should be
embarrassed but we are not where's the
outrage we almost seem to accept this as
being sort of part of a base it's not
you know without protecting your
customers you have no business and I
think forever and this is something that
maybe as a young business as a startup
you didn't think about ten years ago or
five years ago where I think everybody
needs to start with thinking about
oh this is the kind of data I'm
collecting for my customers how am i how
am i protecting my customers you may say
who is interested in when werner rented
this bike here well you know what that
data set plus to all the C's data sets
that you may get from other places may
have a very valuable position so I think
we all need to become extremely security
conscious conscious and make sure that
we can continue to protect our customers
it would be embarrassing I think as
young businesses to actually start
losing your data of your customers it
will impact everybody else in your
environment not just as customers but it
will reflect on other young businesses
as well and I think if you collect data
of your customers if you have consumer
data you have a great responsibility to
keep that data secure and you know
there's also tools for its secure
there's this encryption and we give you
dozens of different tools that all can
help you would do to this but you need
to keep it in your mind that that's your
first and foremost job of course you're
thinking yeah but we don't know we're
building this new surface readability
this new consumer service we don't fit
now I think the only way if you actually
build your your new business without
security Mike it will be very hard to
retrofit it into it and so you will have
a nightmare let's say two three years
down the road when you become successful
and you grow you need to retrofit
security you can't be in a major mess so
that means also that your development
processes because that's what you asked
about need to change now security needs
to become a default part of your for
example your your continuous integration
and continuous DD deployment pipeline
pipeline yeah it needs the trig events
whenever you're building something and
someone adds a new open source library
to it an alarm should be going off for
someone to inspect why are we adding
this why are we doing this do we check
this out from a security point of view
and so your your development pipeline
itself needs to be secure there needs to
be all sorts of alarms coming off in
that whole section and security needs to
become you first and foremost the con
there's lots of automation tools around
it yeah so you deploy you can use Amazon
inspector to test about also to filner
abilities but if you do continuous
integration and contains the deployment
especially if you for example in FinTech
or in healthcare you're subject to also
two regulatory requirements how do you
know that these new next five lines of
codes that you just vote don't violate
your HIPAA yeah or that you're still in
compliance with whatever the financial
regulator wants from from for from you
so if all sort of automation tools that
can continuously test this for you but
you do need to do it and it needs to be
in your mind so development especially
if you do continuous the deployment
changes radically from how we've been
approaching security in the past now I
honestly believe continuous deployment
actually is better from a security point
of view because in the past he would
write 50,000 lines of code security team
would come in would review it would
bless it they had no clue what they were
doing that would bless it 50,000 lines
of code you have no idea yeah and then
you would DTD point changing five lines
of codes it's something that you can
actually test with automated processes
are automatic reasoning and things like
that that you actually are building the
right right right right right things so
I think it is great advances for
security we do need to keep security in
our mind so I hope that in five years
time well not necessarily curity
engineers were all super security
conscious and protecting our customers
will be our first concern it is at
Amazon it will be forever a number one
investment area both in terms of
intellectual capital as well as sort of
in in financial capital protect without
protecting your customers you do not
have a business beyond not taking
security seriously enough are there any
other common mistakes or errors you see
startups doing as they use AWS
well first and foremost I think there's
a technical one so we've got quite a few
people are the for the first time AWS
users but that have already had
experiences with say building services
and using a traditional data center
using AWS as a data center makes it you
lose out I think yeah there are some
advantages to it you have some
elasticity and things are that it you
can make use of but if you don't use
sort of the higher
services and security around data
analytics around mobile all of these
where we take away a lot of the
development for love of the heart let's
say the heavy lifting you're losing out
if you just treat it as a data center
with this on virtual machines a database
and storage it's not that's not where
your major productivity improvements are
coming to come from but not the major
ones next to that sort of a more of a
meta level you have to figure out what
kind of company you are and I think
there's sort of two different companies
to two different starts one of them is
you know you you you go for the
high-growth very far get big fast kind
of thing you know acquire as many
customers as possible as quickly as
possible not necessarily thinking that
much about revenue taking a lot of
investors money and really get big
really fast to become successful and
then probably be acquired because that's
what people interesting you
that's that required that makes you your
use of a degree a senior use of cloud
very different from if you're a mere
supporter really well because you can
become a lot of worry that much about
getting capacity or services whatever
it's all there and it comes with clear
cost picture as well that's different
or if you want to become a sustainable
company basically I want to build this
company but still being business sweetie
is from from for for now you know not
necessarily focused on that position but
just building a business I think if you
guys follow a signal noise the guys from
base camp
you know DHH and others taco and Jason
free talked a lot about how they build a
sustainable how they wanna build they
wanna be in business still they want to
still do this business 10 20 years from
from now how do you do that and that's
that's a very different that requires
different architectures it requires much
more control of a cost it requires a
clear association between cost and
customer acquisition so baby we are
supported as well but it requires you to
build fairly different architectures
because you won't have much more control
of constant scale then in the other one
we another much concerned about cost
you much more concerned about sort of if
they say can be changed really faster we
can address our customer concerns
because we need to grow really fast
Jeff often makes the distinction between
mercenaries and missionaries yeah
mercenaries are the startup founders
that are in it for the money
yeah and missionaries are the ones that
are in it for the love of the product
yeah I want to build this product or I
want to build this business and you
support both of them both fell at the
bow fell at approaches to
enterpreneurship it's just that the
detect support and the tech that you
built for each of each for these
different groups it's very very
different so figure out what you are
alright well thank you so much
this has been wonderful and we've
learned so much and thank everyone a big
thanks to dr. Verner Volvo
[Applause]
you